herr wir reden hier nicht über diese
ganz kleine minderheit nur die irgendwie
nicht mitmacht die dann auch lautstark
ist die zu randale tendiert und so
weiter das ist eine ziemlich große
gruppe die sich bis heute nicht hat
impfen lassen und die sich auch zum
großen teil irgendwie nicht angesprochen
fühlt anscheinend auch hier abwende
trotz aller beteuerung trotz aller
anwerbens dafür sich bitte impfen zu
lassen die fühlt sich bisher nicht
angesprochen diese gruppe von zwölf
millionen deutschen
ja und deswegen muss man das auch
unterscheiden ein teil davon fühlt sich
nicht angesprochen hat ernste sorgen ist
beunruhigt oder was auch immer die kann
man argumentativ überzeugen da muss man
sich kümmern ich habe eben gesagt
argumentation ist da gefragt anstrengung
ist da gefordert da kann sich jeder
darum kümmern und jeder sich bemühen und
der zweite teil der ist wesentlich
kleiner das ist der der dass die
extremistische unterwegs ist der
aggressiv unterwegs als ihnen eigentlich
glaubt gegen den staat zu orientieren
das ja aber das sind 12 millionen ist ja
vollkommen klar ist es ist ein kleiner
teil davon aber der das geht doch nicht
im großen kleinen der teile ist
gefährlich und deswegen müssen wir das
ernst nehmen ich bin da auch
hundertprozentig dagegen zu sagen das
ist nur eine kleine gruppe kümmern damit
links liegen das nein nein wir sind
brandgefährlich weil sie eben
mittlerweile nicht nur reden schmerzen
sich gegenseitig mit stacheln sondern
auch zutaten schreit sie haben vorher
sinnvoll schon sie in einer frage die
weitere vergangenen sechs rennen heraus
versammlungsrecht vielleicht können sie
das noch einmal sagen was kann man da
machen was wollen sie da machen
also wir bei uns sind auch das fahren
machen ein neues versammlungsrecht und
wir wollen ein paar regeln haben die
gelten aber dann für alle die
versammlungen schützen weil das ja ein
ganz ganz hohes gut ist aber
gleichzeitig auch sicherstellt dass sie
nicht gestört werden können würden von
für irgendwelche verrückten oder das
einer der versammlung durchführt aus
sich an bestimmte regeln halten muss
damit es nicht drunter und drüber geht
und dahinter steckt natürlich eigentlich
die hoffnung dass man diejenigen die
freiheitlich demonstrieren wollen die
ein anliegen haben das muss in unserer
gesellschaft möglich sein auch wenn die
die komischen anliegen haben müssen sich
darstellen können aber es gibt grenzen
die dürfen nicht gewalt anwenden und die
anderen die mehrheit die damit unterwegs
ist und denkt sie protestiert für ein
tolles anliegen die muss kapieren sie
machen sich mitschuldig ich finde die
frage geht nicht nur an diejenigen die
gewalttätig sind sondern auch an die
anderen die mitläufer ich will das mal
so nennen die deutsche gesellschaft die
deutsche geschichte ist voll von
entwicklungen wo mitläufer dazu
beigetragen haben dass die gesellschaft
hat der staat sich falsch entwickelt hat
insofern mitläufer passt auf lasst euch
nicht missbrauchen kümmert euch geht so
alleine demonstrieren aber trennt euch
von denen die da ganz andere absichten